hey guys Pete here just got done
rewatching Westworld season 1 episode 4
and this will be my scene-by-scene
breakdown gonna do episode 4 lucky I did
episode 3 so after I finished this I
will do a separate summary video that
I'll release later I'll put a link up in
the description and a card here that you
can click on now keep in mind this will
contain spoilers for everything that's
happening in West West world up to this
point so if you haven't seen through
episode 4 yet you'll want to stop
watching now let's jump into the episode
we find the Loras and Barnard in the
programming Center we assume this is
right after we saw her collapse and
Williams arms at the end of the last
episode Barnard is asking her questions
alone and when he asks if she remembers
what happened before this she says that
someone hurt her family that they killed
them and that she ran Bernard has her
limit her emotional effect and when she
says that it hurts to lose everyone she
cared about he says he can make that
feeling go away she asked why would she
want that and then says the pain and
loss was all she had left of it this was
the same thing that Bernard said to his
wife when she asked if sometimes he
wished he could forget about their son's
death they go back and forth while she
tries to explain the changes she's
experiencing Dolores asked if there is
something wrong with her or if Bernard
can help when he asks her what she wants
she can only answer that she doesn't
know she goes on to say that she thinks
there is something wrong with this world
or that maybe she's losing her mind
Bernard then says he wants her to try a
game it's a secret that's called the
maze he tells her that if she can find
the center of it maybe she can be free
she says I think I want to be free
we then see her wake up in Williams camp
with a gun in her hand he gives her a
cup of coffee and we cut back to the
mariposa Maeve asked Clementine if she
ever has a feeling that she has
something on the tip of her tongue but
just can't remember it they continue
making small talk when then Maeve starts
to glitch out she starts remembering a
guest walking through and shooting all
the hosts and see him walk over to her
and shoot she then sees the text dragged
Clementine away and has a partial memory
of being repaired we hear one of the
techs say that they need to get her back
on the floor and the other says he's not
done yet that there's still a bullet
fragment inside of her
but the other text says just go ahead
and patch her up she then comes to and
we see that they're back into that same
conversation they were having earlier
she leaves the mariposa and goes to her
room on the way if she's very skittish
and looks disoriented when she gets
there she looks in the mirror and then
grabs a piece of paper to start
sketching when she's looking at the
mirror she's sort of looking at where
she was shot she draws a picture of the
text she's seen in her memories and
pulls up a floorboard to hide it when
she looks under the floor she finds a
pile of similar drawings that it doesn't
look like she remembers back at the
center Elsie is talking with Teresa and
Stubbs we see the stray with his smashed
in head sitting in the chair and Teresa
is asking if they figured out what
happened to make him go off his loot
Bernard comes in and when else he says
that they're working to figure out what
went wrong Teresa tells them that her
team will take over she says qat will
handle all cases of this nature from now
on an aspirin our DIF he has any
objections he lets her take the stray
and then leaves with Elsie falling
behind
Elsie is upset because she feels like
something beyond the glitch is going on
and that Bernard doesn't want her to
tell anyone she says it's like everyone
has an agenda except for her and then he
tells her that she's imagining things in
much the same way for told him not to
see things that weren't there he tells
her that the hosts don't imagine things
you do he then tells her that the
pattern on the shell is not a Ryan
because arrive has three stars on its
belt not four back at the camp William
gives Dolores his jacket because she
looks like she's cold he goes over to
tell Logan that they should take her
back to Sweetwater but the Bounty
Hunter's Howe says they need to get
moving or Slim's gonna get away Logan
says no way and William eventually stops
arguing with him about it if I know that
Logan has ulterior motives related to
business
and that he thinks the park sent Dolores
on purpose he says that the company
should up their stake in Westworld
because they can even give William a
purpose William says he thought the trip
was about welcoming him into the family
and Logan responds by saying that his
with his family everything is about
business the man in black still has
Lawrence with his noose and he's found
what he thinks should be the blood
Arroyo
he says he can't find any snakes of the
egg-laying variety and Lawrence asked
him what he hopes to fun
the man in black says that this whole
world is a story and he's read every
page except the last one he wants to
find out how it ends as Lawrence is
trying to talk to talk him into leaving
he sees Armistice bathing in the river
he notices her giant snake tattoo and
says he thinks they found their snake
her men come up behind him and pulled
their guns when she walks up he says how
he's never met her and it's a terrible
oversight on his part and ask her where
she's going she says she's going after
something with great value and he asked
to join her party he kills two of her
men and then says it looks like you
could use a couple more guys attack
comes up to Stubb's to tell him that the
ranchers daughter is taking a pretty big
deviation from her loot he asked the
tech if she's with a guest and the text
says she can't tell because the boss has
disrupted so many things with his new
story he tells her to have behavior flag
her and have them check her out later in
the day the lorises at the small Mexican
town where Lawrence is from she looks at
the well and then sees Lawrence's
daughter sitting by herself she
approaches her an asset that's her home
when the young girl says no Dolores
asked her where she's from the girl says
same as you don't you remember when she
hears the word remember Dolores hears
Ford's voice and has a flashback she
sees the white church with a steeple
that Ford was looking at in the empty
part of the park the same place he took
Bernard - later she sees the young girl
in a church dress the girl hits the
sticks she's scratching the dirt with on
the ground and Dolores sees the doors of
the church divorce looks at the ground
and she sees the pattern of the maize
scratched in the dirt the girl
disappears and a random man approaches
her he tells her that they've heard a
girl went missing from Abernathy branch
she asks if that's where she's supposed
to be and tells her that her father must
be worried she stops when he says this
and then has a flash where she sees
herself walking up to the church doors
she sees a gun in her hand then she sees
herself on the ground in front of a
grave she tells the man that her
father's dead and that she's not going
back he grabs a hold of her arm and then
William comes out asking what's going on
the man says he's just helping a lost
traveler to which William responds she's
not lost she's with me and then the man
goes away William tells Dolores that
they have a
on the bounty and says she can just wait
there for them to get back she says no I
think I'm to keep going and they walk
off together we see the man in black
with Lawrence and armistice men on a
ridge in the canyon Lawrence says
they're supposed to wait for a signal
from armistice if the information she
has is good we see her ride up to two
Cowboys on horses after saying something
to them she kills them both and the man
in black says that that must have been
the signal William and his companions
are making camp again dolores says she's
sorry if she made trouble between him
and his friend William says it's fine
and ask her where she's headed she says
she doesn't know and what he says that
he thought they kept them in zones or
paths Thor says she used to believe
everyone had a path and tells him a
story about driving the cattle back home
in the fall how they would lose one
every once in a while and she had
worried it wouldn't be able to find its
way back she says it never occurred to
her that they were bringing them back
for the slaughter
William asks how she's going to find her
way now and she says sometimes she feels
like something is calling her telling
her there's a place for her beyond all
of this when she looks at the moon she
has another flashback this time from
outside the ranch she sees the text
coming to collect the host bodies and
then she starts to faint
William catches her and tells her they
should get back to the fire because
she's probably exhausted two other
guests approached the man in black at
the bandits campfire the one tries to
tell him he's a big admirer he starts to
say something like his foundation
literally saved my sisters and the man
in black says one more word and I'll cut
your throat this is my vacation Lawrence
tells the man in black that apparently
what armistice and her men are looking
for is at the prison he says they plan
on stealing a cannon from the Calvary
and the man in black says he doesn't
have time for all that he approaches
armistice and tells her that he'll ride
at dawn to get her what she needs from
the prison all he wants in return are a
few words he then asked her if she's
ever heard of a man named Arnold who he
says could be considered the original
settler settler of these parts he
created a world where you could do
anything you want except one thing you
can't die which means no matter how real
this world seems it's just a game then
Arnold broke his own rule he died right
they're in the par he says he believes
he still had one story left to tell and
then pulls out the scalp with the maze
on it from his jacket as he shows it to
her he says a real story with real
stakes real violence you could say I'm
here to honor his legacy and I think
your tattoo is the next piece of the
puzzle she agrees to his offer and he
says he only needs one match in Lawrence
we're not seen with Lawrence handcuffed
and an armored stagecoach headed towards
the prison he pulls out some cigars and
the deputy tells them he can't smoke in
there he tells a story about how it's
the finest tobacco rolled on the ample
thighs of exotic women he asked if he
would like to try one himself and the
deputy takes the two remaining cigars
and the case he then gives a speech
about choices to Lawrence who he says
has always been a prisoner he says what
if I told you I'm here to set you free
when they get to the prison the warden
recognizes Lawrence and says he heard
that he had escaped the hangman's noose
the man in black says maybe he prefers a
firing squad and the warden says he's
sure they'll be able to oblige him he
then has the deputy to take the man in
black inside and put him in a Cell with
Hector as the warden his men walk
Lawrence to be executed the man in black
and Hector have a conversation
men in black pulls out the match he got
from Armistice and then goes over to
light the cigar we we see at this point
the attack at the center say that they
have a request for a pyrotechnic effect
stub approves it and we see Lawrence
tied to the post in front of the firing
squad the man in black puts the lit
cigar in the lock of the jail cell where
it explodes so they can get out as the
deputy comes out to stop them the cigar
in his mouth explodes allowing those two
walking out of the prison without any
trouble they go outside killed the
warden and his men and free Lawrence
they get Hector back to armistice who
tries to offer to pay them back the man
in black says he just needs a word or
two with her and then she tells him the
story of the tattoo she explains that
she was 7 when they rode into town men
in masks they killed everyone there and
killed her mother by cutting her from
the jaw to her sex she says she used her
mother's blood to paint her skin to make
it look like she was dead she says she
hunted down all the men and used their
blood to paint her skin again the man in
black says only one man left for the
head which isn't it's the only part that
isn't filled in yet of the tattoo he
asked her what the last man's name is
and she tells him that
Wyatt back in sweetwater there's a group
of Indian families being run out of town
the townspeople are watching while Maeve
notices a young girl drop a doll that
looks like the text in the hazmat suits
she runs after the girl to give it back
and when she asked what it is the girl
doesn't say anything at all a nearby
soldier tells her that she's wasting a
breath because it's a part of their
so-called religion and none of them are
gonna tell her anything about that
inside the mariposa Clementine is
talking to the guest that was riding
with Armistice and one of her men when
she comes over me so she recognizes him
from Hector's gang Clementine asked if
she means the one who lives out with the
savages which makes that makes me think
back to the little girls doll she tells
Clementine yes and looks like she has a
plan that involves talking to Hector
Teresa is at Bernards place where they
have a similar conversation the last one
we saw them have there about her staying
for a while in the conversation she
tells him that she's meeting with Ford
the next day when he asked why she says
that he's creating chaos in the park and
that the board will be descending at any
moment he gives her advice to not show
him that she's nervous or defensive we
see her fine Ford who's working on a
large-scale renovation she tells him
that his new narrative looks to be on a
massive scale and that she can have the
board give him more time he says he's
sure they'd like to postpone it
indefinitely and then tells her to come
with him they walk off and we see hosts
working on the project everywhere as
they go they end up in a restaurant
overlooking an agave plantation and he
says that she thinks he's gone mad or
maybe lost his way she says they're
merely concerned with the extent of the
changes he's making and that they want
to protect his legacy he sort of laughs
at that and says you don't like it here
do you she tells him that she admires
the place and that she came there as a
child with her family she adds that she
may have sat at that very table and then
goes on to say that when she started
working there she realized that this
place was not something that she would
enjoy he tells her that in the beginning
he imagined things would be perfectly
balanced and that he even had a bet with
his partner Arnold about it he says they
made a hundred hopeful storylines that
almost no one took them up on and that
he eventually lost the bet
he says Arnold always had a somewhat dim
view of people that he preferred the
and that he begged them to not let you
people in the money men Della's he says
he told him that they would be fine
because Delos didn't know what they were
paying for it wasn't a business venture
not a theme park but an entire world as
he's saying this a host pouring wine for
them gets frozen and wine starts to
overflow he goes on with the story
saying they designed every inch of it
and in here they were gods
Teresa looks around and noticed that all
the hosts she can see are frozen in
place as if time has Stood Still he
finishes by saying that they were merely
their guests
she looks uncomfortable and lights a
cigarette she asks and how did that work
out for Arnold
he says sadly he lost his perspective he
went mad I haven't as you well know I
have always seen things very clearly she
responds that this is the table i sat at
with my parents this is the chair i sat
in he smiles and says we know everything
about our guests don't we as we know
everything about our employees he says I
do hope you will be careful with Bernard
he has a sensitive disposition right
then the hosts come back online and we
see from the side view that he points
his finger to make that happen he goes
on to say that there have been many of
you over the years and we've almost
always found a way to make it work so
I'll ask you nicely please don't get in
my way she gives him a look stands up to
leave and says the board will agree with
her and we'll be sending a
representative he says they already have
and that he thought she would have
already known when the host comes back
to the table to clean up the spill for
tells them that it won't be necessary
and that he can he can go ahead and join
the others now at this point we see that
things are shaking and Teresa gets up to
see what's going on he says she can tell
the board that his narrative will be
done on time and that it won't be a
retrospective which he is sure they've
all feared we see this giant earthmoving
machine cutting into the hillside and
then he finishes by telling her he isn't
the sentimental type we find William and
Dolores outside Slim's hideout he tells
her that she's going to have to stay
back
since slim has them outnumbered when she
tries to come along anyways he explains
that he can't be hurt in there but she
can so he needs her to wait outside the
Bounty Hunter Logan and William enter
the place guns blazing to kill
Slim's mad they're able to get their man
it looks like they have a pretty fun
time doing it the man in black is riding
with Lawrence who tells him he thinks
their plan is crazy he indicates that
their plan is to go after Wyatt with
just the two of them he tells him he's
not gonna get himself killed and as
they're riding they find Teddy tied to a
tree he asked a man in black to put him
out of his misery to which he replies
that he's sorry but it looks like
miseries all you got the scene ends with
him cutting Teddy down Williams group is
rotting slim back to town when Logan
gets the idea to gag him they stop and
slim pleads with him saying that he
knows they're just in it for the money
he says his boss Alonzo will pay double
the bounty and when Logan hears this he
shoots the bounty hunter on the spot
William freaks out and Logan tells them
that Alonzo is their ticket to one of
the best rides in the park that Williams
[ __ ] mission led them straight to an
easter egg the two have a standoff where
they both pull their guns on the host
and then Logan tells them that this is
going to be fun he asked him to go black
hat with him William asked what's wrong
with them as soon as they get away from
the real world he turns into an evil
prick Logan them reminds him that it's a
game and asked him if he's still trying
to impress Dolores he says he can tell
him that she doesn't give a [ __ ] about
how he plays the game and she asks what
they're talking about
Logan says she'll be alright with the
trip down the dark side and so will
William we then see them ride off with
Logan asking slim for directions to
pariah at the programming center of the
tech store watching Hector's gang ride
into town with the guests who've joined
them this time stub says let's give them
something to shoot at and has the tech
retask a few soldiers the narrative
starts the same way as usual we see them
start shooting up the street when Hector
comes inside for the safe Mei pulls her
derringer on him and tells him she wants
to have a talk she takes him upstairs
and offers to give him the combination
to the safe in exchange for some answers
she shows him the drawing that she made
and says that she wants to know what's
what it's about he tells her it's called
a shade and that the narratives to make
figures out of them
he says it walks through worlds that it
was sent from Hell to oversee their work
one of the text tells Stubbs that there
as a family coming from the homestead
into town so he has her jam their guns
and get everything cleared up in the
street
Maeve tells Hector she thought she was
crazy and asked him to cut her with his
knife that she got shot and that she saw
the shades too
over her and then it was like nothing
happened he doesn't want to cut into her
but tells her that the Dreamwalker say
that there were some people who could
see them that it was a blessing from God
to see them to see the Masters that pull
your strings she eventually stabs a
knife into herself and tells him to
reach inside he finds and pulls out the
shell with the tech left inside her
earlier when Hector asks what it all
means she says that it means she's not
crazy and that none of this matters as
the sheriff shows up at the door she
kisses him and they eventually get shot
up through the door the episode ends
there and even though the pace was a
little slower I think we learned a lot
I'll be working on my summary video for
part two so make sure you check back for
that soon if you have any questions
leave them in the comments and I'll try
to answer them all I'm thinking about
the revelation that Logan is there for
business and just how much of a badass
dr. Ford is when he wants to show off
the main stuff is getting real and I'm
liking the twist that some of the hosts
have an idea of what's going on in the
park
of course the Dolores stuff is
interesting and it'll be cool to see who
this Alonso character is not to mention
she's looking for the maze and the man
in black is looking for the maze at the
same time and even though they're not
going in the same direction there's a
good chance that their paths may cross
soon so there'd be a lot to talk about
no doubt about that please like the
video if you enjoyed it and subscribe to
my channel so you know when the next one
comes out thanks for watching I'll talk
to you soon